[Music]
okay everybody I'm so excited today
because I am joined by Gillian Jacobs
and Corey Michael Smith who star in
transatlantic which is out Friday on
Netflix how you guys doing today great
how are you I'm doing great I'm so
excited to talk to you guys I absolutely
love the show I'm excited for people to
see it as well now my first question is
for Gillian uh the costumes of Mary Jane
are spectacular
why the hell did you keep all those hats
on a lot of pins
and secret netting no it was a feat of
engineering between the costume designer
and the hairdresser they did a very good
teamwork but yeah there are times if a
strong wind comes along you really you
know you instinctively hand to hack
because you don't want it to go flying
off and there are some wins in Marseille
it's actually known for its wind
oh wow interesting yeah no that's
awesome I know I'm thinking of it yeah
there's a there's a special very strong
wind in Marseille that hits right around
the time we were filming so yes I did
actually have to worry about the hats oh
wow that's a great new thing I learned
today thank you
uh Corey how did you go about finding
that sweet spot for your betrayal of
Varian fry meaning like between the real
life version your take and the book
version
um I well that's really
Anna uh you know she this is this is
Anna's show she
adapted uh you know the the show to meet
the needs of of telling a dramatic story
um you know Julie's novel the flight
portfolio
uh inspired Anna's work but she really
wanted the focus of the emergency rescue
committee to be more holistic and that
meant taking this incredible collection
of characters and creating a story where
you know everyone is sort of feeding
into and collaborating together and
making everyone's story sort of grow so
you know there are some things about
varian's story that are shared with
other characters and it's it's kind of
that way with everyone
um
you know an example excuse me an example
uh you know Varian fry uh worked with
British intelligence while he was there
and in our show
that's a major point of conflict between
Mary Jane gold and Varian fry because
Mary Jane is working with British
intelligence and it really infuriates
Varian because it puts the mission at
risk so there are some things that
happen in in telling story where you
know especially with historical fiction
where you need to adjust some things but
most importantly
I think the Ambitions the intention of
all of the characters regardless of some
things changing is very honest and true
and that's that's really what's most
important when telling the story yeah I
I love that answer and that's a great
point about how it is like a unique take
on it but it keeps that truth there at
the center
um Gillian what was the number one trait
about Mary Jane you want to make sure
you conveyed clear to the audience the
most hmm
these are great questions
um
I think
her desire to help which I think is both
true to the real woman and you know the
version of her that exists in the show
um both of our characters as Americans
in 1940 before the US has entered the
war had the ability to leave at any
moment so they have this unique
privilege of being able to leave
and she chose to say stay for as long as
she could and help and I think that that
is a remarkable thing
um but once again as Corey said that was
there in Anna's writing so
um I felt free from trying to convey
anything to the audience and I just
tried to do my best to live up to the
scripts and the the real life story no
100 I love your betrayal lover and she's
so likable and I love she takes action
so really good job on your part too and
then Corey I was gonna say that people
will see in episode two there's some
really powerful scenes where your
character is doing interviews and he
gets very emotional does doing heavy
content like this suck the life out of
you emotionally sometimes on set like is
there something about that
um you know I'm still as an actor
working through my relationship with
material what I prefer
um
one of the strange things that happens I
mean
when I feel like an emotional cost
portraying a character I I feel more
deeply connected to this person they
feel more real to me
um
so you know when I feel like deeply
connected to a character's psyche or
their intentions their ambition
it like it really sinks into you it's
like it becomes part of your nervous
system and so like characters like
Varian really live with you for a long
time and what you're referencing
uh toward the end well I guess it's sort
of in the middle of of episode two where
he's doing his interviews with the
refugees
it's such an important part of the
series for me
um and and I'm really proud of how it it
turned out with the editing and all of
these wonderful uh you know players that
came in and are sharing these stories of
regular people going through these you
know this horrendous experience of being
displaced
you know Varian is
initially on a mission of helping
sort of established
um
sometimes wealthy uh privilege a
privileged class of society Escape
because these are people that have value
to
um you know
with regard to meritocracy going to
America you know there it's it's okay
and allowed for them to go over but all
of these other people are sort of
unwanted
you know uh these Jewish refugees who
don't have status are sort of unwanted
in America at that point in history and
he's dealing with this you know this
conflict of saying you know we have a
mission these are people that we can
help with the state department and Mary
Jane gold is really responsible for
pushing him and pushing him of saying
you know there are so many more people
that we can help that need our help
and it's it's a moment of of internal
conflict sort of spilling out of him
um at that moment and I think it's a
really important uh part of varian's
trajectory in his evolution
yeah and I love that scene and it's one
that's going to stick with me and I'm
excited for the audience to see and
that's just a great answer going more
into it
um Gillian What I Love About Mary Jane
is a relationship with her dog
Barrett
um do you get it attached to dog actors
and how do you say goodbye you know it's
really funny because you're not really
allowed to interact with them that much
when you're not shooting so you don't
have as much of a relationship with them
as you would like a friend's dog that
you go over and play with or a trained
animal who's being taught commands and
you're really not supposed to like mess
with them too much to throw them off so
it's a strange thing where you you spend
much more time with them between action
and cut than you do the rest of the time
but that's a pretty cute dog I mean I
was a less secure actress I'd be worried
about him stealing Focus because that
face come on I mean
yeah no I love it and there's great
chemistry between you and the dog so
Props to you uh and Corey is gonna ask
you you know it's just great party scene
in episode three there's actually a
unicycle that shows up did you ever try
to get on this unicycle no let me tell
you
that unicycle was very tall yes the man
that was writing that was uh suspended
quite uh high in the air in fact there
were a lot of acrobats doing some pretty
wild stuff it was very very impressive
people standing on shoulders and heads
and flipping around it was a it was a
lovely uh it was a lovely thing to have
so much energy like circus energy
because we were filming that over the
night so you know it's like 4 30.
everyone is dead but we have acrobats
going like losing their minds so it was
nice yeah and I love you mentioning
circus energy that's really what sums up
a lot in that episode which I think is
really cool I think people are really
gonna enjoy
um before I let you guys go Gillian I
have to ask do you ever Tire of all the
Brita references that we see like out
there or do you embrace it do you relish
it I absolutely embrace it I mean how
lucky am I that I was part of a show
that people are still talking about this
many years later so that is nothing but
good fortune on my behalf it's the show
that gave me the career that I have now
so I totally embrace it I am Brita for
life I love that answer and that's
awesome that you're so cool about it um
Everybody watch Gillian and Corey
absolutely crush it in transatlantic
Friday on Netflix thank you guys so much
for joining me at a blast I hope to talk
to you in the future thank you so much
great interview thank you so much